my wife and I have been taking our
health a lot more seriously lately I
mean you guys saw how I looked like just
a few years ago and with that we
realized how expensive a lot of this
kind of equipment costs so this right
here is the yo G1 and they reached out
wanting to sponsor a showcase and a
comparison to the pelaton now the insane
thing is this pelaton cost
$2,500
that is more than my first car that I
purchased and the eso cost
$399 with our coupon code in the video
description so you guys can check it out
now you would think that would mean
there is a massive difference in quality
and features and that's where you would
be wrong and I was really surprised as
well as you guys can see the design is
similar but what shocked me is that the
build quality quality is also very
similar in fact looking at all the welds
and the details on the EO the welds
actually look better and it actually
came in better condition whereas the
pelaton had scuffs on there some
scratches and even some rust on the
bottom which blew my mind ESO makes
cardio fun because you can stream
Netflix or anything else completely free
so you can have fun and watch whatever
you'd like while you're exercising and
with that you can spin the screen around
and you can get your kids involved or
just turn on some videos that they enjoy
for them to sit and watch while you're
having your cardio time with that the
yeso is so easy to put together in fact
my 10-year-old and my six-year-old did
it completely by themselves now the
pelaton on the other hand was much much
more difficult and I did it myself cuz
they didn't want to wait 2 weeks for
them to be able to come and set it up
there's a lot more parts in definitely
takes longer now of course the pelaton
does have some areas where it is better
than the yo and with that my wife has
been using this for a while now and
there are multiple areas where she likes
this bike better and one of those areas
is the flexibility not only do you have
a low price tag so it's easy to buy it
it's a lot more affordable um and if you
don't know if you're going to love
cycling well you're not going to risk a
ton of money but with that they also do
have an app and the app costs 10 bucks a
month instead of
$44 a month which is insane now I'll
talk about that in just a bit but I
think the coolest thing is that ESO does
not lock you down now with the pelaton
you have this display with a tablet
built in and you need to be using their
software to use it now they've come out
with a little bit of updates before that
it was locked in but with the eso you
don't have to just use that app you can
actually stream anything you want to the
display so you can literally AirPlay to
to it so if you want to watch something
from YouTube you want to watch some of
our videos or really any app you can do
that and then with that you can just
plug in an HDMI to the back even to get
adapter for your phone and just uh cast
your screen or from the tablet you can
even get get the Pelon app if you prefer
that and run it on this bike so it's
really cool to see that flexibility and
not have it be so locked down now the
app is packed with different workouts
and features so you can go through
regular classes you can stream different
Scenic rides and those are really cool
um you can actually take the display and
twist it just like you can on the peltin
bike plus so it actually um adjusts to
the side so there's a lot of other
workouts and things that you could do
the app has over 500 coaches with live
on demand classes and challenges for a
lot of other stuff so even if you are on
the go and you don't have your bike with
you you could still use it um there's
leaderboards uh information from your
previous workouts it's a really packed
good app that does not cost so much
money like the pelaton app does and when
you're working out you have your Cadence
you have your power you have um your
tension adjustment displayed on the
screen with a lot of other metrics um
right when you're starting working out
how much time you have left all of that
is built in and shown on your display
and you power that through your phone
whereas with a pelaton you mostly do
that through the display which is a
touchscreen on the pelaton now the
display here it's a little sharper you
have speakers that do get a little bit
louder compared to the yo um but
unfortunately there's nothing you can
plug in no inputs on the back um so they
really want to lock you down to their
system now with that this bike for 400
bucks using our code below actually
comes with the rack it comes with
dumbbells your water bottle holder and
it comes with regular pedals where you
just use regular shoes and you don't
have to go out and spend 145 bucks on
the pelaton shoes like I bought for this
pelaton so even though it costs two
$2,500 it does not come with the
dumbbells or the shoes or other
accessories now what about the actual
riding experience well my wife has been
loving it um one thing she mentioned is
that the yo has a softer more
comfortable seat and with more
comfortable handlebars than the pelaton
has now the pelaton is quite a bit
heavier um so it does have a little bit
more stability but when you're working
out you still see that same side to side
Shake uh just like you do on on the yo
they're pretty much the same now as far
as adjustments they all have similar
adjustments so you can go ahead and you
can move the seat backwards you can
raise up the seat you can raise up and
extend the front of the asso so make it
longer so pretty much the same exact
adjustments that you get on the pelaton
the screen can tilt and adjust um one
difference though is that with Theo
these adjustments can actually pull back
and then you do the final tighten
instead of having to un screw it all the
way so that is nice and then with that
another thing my wife mentioned is that
the water bottle holder is a lot closer
to you right up here instead of being
mounted down here so when you adjust
your bike and you raise it um the
distance is further away from you now
another thing is that the tensioner
adjustment um it is magnetic it's not
friction based like you get on a lot of
lower pric bikes that's nice um the
pelon's also magnetic now this one with
the bike plus does have automatic uh
tensioner adjustments if you are in a
class that is supporting that so that is
nice and then with the pelaton you also
have a webcam built into here if you
want to use that with that you can also
connect your Apple watch to the display
so that you can get that information on
the screen instead of connecting it to
your watch and then having that connect
with an app and seeing your data that
way so if you're looking for an exercise
bike I would highly suggest checking out
the yeso
um they do have free shipping with no
taxes a great price they have a return
policy and they've been around since
2016 making bikes and the app they have
a red dot award they have a lot of great
reviews that you guys can check out
online so you can pick up something like
this that is shockingly good for the
money you can use their app or use
another app have a lot of
flexibility and it is just really wellb
built and works great or if you want to
you can pick up a pelaton but for the
amount of money that this thing costs
even if you can afford it it is a tough
pill to swallow and then again it's also
very locked down with what you could do
with it and then the amount of money you
have to pay each and every single month
to be able to use it that just gets a
little bit crazy so thank you guys for
watching I wish you guys the best on
your health Journey um and we will see
you guys in the next video